[Applause]
holidays we want to shine a light on the
millions of moms out there making
Christmas happen all on their own
Kevin and I both were actually raised by
single mothers both of us know firsthand
it ain't easy but somehow these super
women make miracles happen for their
families that includes my next guest
she's a single mom from Kevin's hometown
actually a Philadelphia
please welcome Andre y'all just like
heaven I am from New Philadelphia
I'm a 25 year old single mother of two
amazing boys my oldest son his name is
Talon I'm he's 6 years old he's my
little bodyguard my youngest son's name
is mozzie he's autistic special needs he
has a lot of sensory issues so he
requires a lot of attention and care
well right now you know all three of us
are sharing a single room and my parents
home it's very crowded no every hard to
study there but you know yeah aren't you
also you're studying to be a nurse right
great good nursing all right Vince how
do you do that I don't know I just get
up every day and just you know try to
keep my head up and remain positive and
do what I have to do it's very hard so
you've had a setback what happened I
found out that my financial aid will not
cover my last year and there's his
school so I need your last year yep my
last year so I'm sorry that's okay so oh
my gosh wait Oh see I cry so often they
leave see thank you um so you know right
now you know I've been desperate I
talked to this school I tried to apply
for scholarships I don't have the best
credit so I'm unable to apply for
personal loans so you know right now I
have to drop out of nursing school and I
don't have one more year you know I've
been really depressed about it I'm a few
days ago I had to go in my closet and
cry because it makes me feel like a
failure as a mother because oh my god
first of all what you were earlier as a
mom I've cried in my bed with a bottle
and a glass of wine you
not all of us go through that it doesn't
matter if dad's go through that every
parent goes through that you want to you
want the best life for your kid and you
try so hard and some days just don't
work out well as I mentioned earlier
both Kevin and I were raised by single
mamas we know the holidays can be tough
so Kevin what's something Andreev really
needs to understand I think the the best
thing to realize is that you've done so
well thus far you know you talked about
two boys that you're raising and that
you're providing for and you're
multitasking from working to school you
you've already done a lot you've already
checked a lot of positive boxes and I
think sometimes it's important to really
recognize and realize what's happened
before we focus on the thing that we
feel hasn't happened I'm not the most
spiritual person but I believe the guy
he puts the toughest battles on some of
his strongest soldiers so nothing that
you can't handle is not what you're
going through like this is all a part of
a plan who's playing I don't know but
it's supposed to happen for a reason and
it's only making you stronger it's only
making you better and the better that
you become the much better that those
boys will become later on in life but
you got to check those positive boxes
and not the negative ones that's the
first piece right now
single moms pull off miracles for their
kids and I have no doubt Andreya would
pull off a miracle for hers but since
it's the season of miracles let's help
her out
I think aundrea Kevin and I want to
Jumanji thighs for Christmas yes we do
yeah Jumanji sighs we heard your oldest
loves dinosaurs so he's all set thank
you oh my gosh no we would thank you for
being such an inspiring mama like the
year has shown us that people are
working hard
okay people we're off to a good start
but um I did say Jumanji sighs no let's
take things to the next level right come
in that's not yeah yes we can go figure
smile man elf had the deepest voice I've
ever heard in my life that mercury just
growl at me Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas comes directly from Kevin
Kevin tell her about it well let me tell
you first of all when I have partners I
feel like my partners have to be a
representation of me and Tommy John is a
partner of mine that I've been in
business with for quite some time and we
believe in quality and comfort and we
wanted to give you in your household a
bunch of quality and comfort from
loungewear to underwear to socks you
name it we put it in there
but when we were talking I was like
that's just a piece of it I was like
having them look good and feel good and
in a family environment where they're
comfortable that's one side but one of
the best things that can make you most
comfortable it's taking away stress so I
said let's take it up a notch so my part
of the Tommy John we kicked out $25,000
to take care
[Music]
so like I said like I said I want people
to really understand something okay
you never know what blessing you have
coming your way you never know what
tomorrow holds and we'll it will bring
all you can do is be prepared for the
best side of it and right now listening
to you talk the way you talk today and
muster up the energy to tell your story
and try to hold back emotion you're more
than deserving of this moment you're
more to prepare to finish your task and
become one of the best versus best
nurses that you can be I'm about to get
you need to stop okay you're affecting
my positive speech okay basically when
I'm saying make him cry be better nurses
and I think we just got one so go
[Applause]
if actually getting Tommy John clothing
as well
[Applause]
amazing
this has gotta be a just a burden just
lifted off right I didn't expect
anything I always say expectations
brings disappointment so I didn't expect
anything this is amazing thank you let's
write not around wait expectations
reena's with no should expect what you
want and desire knit will find its way
to you there you go right now I'm going
to show you the room you get my two
children I share inside my parents on
their total ten people living here I am
also living out of control because
there's not much space in my room come
on in really tight in here shoes clothes
I just try to utilize all the space that
I can I have things under the bed right
here I made this little library for my
boys they really like when I read to
them here's my study area I've shoes
under the desks I have nowhere else to
put them it's really hard to study right
here when my boys are just right behind
me on the bed exercise it's very crowded
in here I'm just trying to do the best I
can to make it work you know I have to
do it I have to do so that was a tour of
the room she shares with her two boys
right now she lives in a house with ten
other people before the break Kevin and
I do man G sized her Christmas with toys
and a scholarship to finish nursing
school well we said um Morgan and
Jumanji sighs her Christmas ryankevin we
did say that have we done that I don't
think I don't think we've completely
Jumanji sized Jumanji is a big movie yes
that's a really big move exactly I feel
like we're it's definitely under the bar
at this yeah and at a bar I think we can
go there's another level okay that can
be reached reach another level all right
let's take this Jumanji
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
our friends at Xfinity also heard
ondrea's story and wanted to help
Xfinity is providing her and her boys
with a newly remodeled and newly
furnished two-bedroom apartment all for
them all free for one whole year
Xfinity knows that the Internet has the
incredible power to keep us all
connected because of this Xfinity is
also making sure entre and her kids stay
connected with free internet service for
a year that is so helpful with studying
I know that and we have Miguel Martinez
bye-yay from our Philly affiliate NBC 10
standing by for a grand tour of ondrea's
new place look at that monitor I'm so
excited to show you your new home I'm
gonna give you a little tour here Andre
it's beautiful in here let's take a look
around so when you walk in the front
door the first place you're gonna see is
your bedroom the boys they get their own
bedroom you know they get bunk beds
right there you can see how to train
your dragon' theater in here it's
beautiful
it comes complete right next to your
room which own space I mean we were
talking about space earlier looking at
your own beautiful bed and take a look
at that desk I know you're finishing up
nursing school that is a prime study
location just for you Andrea
and then right here this is the family
space so you get the kitchen brand new
stainless steel appliances brand new
grechka countertops and everything right
next to the living room so you get that
new TV from our friends over at Xfinity
and take a look behind me here because
it's the holiday season a beautiful
decorated Christmas tree and presents
for the whole family so this beautiful
space it is right next to where you're
currently living so just a few blocks
away the kids they can stay in their own
school it's so close to where you are
now but this it's your own so I don't
know Andrea how do you feel oh my god I
am just blessed and grateful I did not
expect this thank you from the bottom of
my heart do you think your boys are
gonna like
oh they'll love it well you have mikela
don't you have some special visitors
right there with you I do I do I have
special guests so actually guys come in
here Kalin and mozzie are here they're
gonna see for the first time hey guys
come in here come in here look around
this space is yours these gifts are for
you this Christmas alright boys do you
want to see your bedroom
alright let's run in the back throw it
straight over here you're gonna see all
the how to train your dragons they're
gonna go take a look at their bedroom
look at those bunk beds you feeling
excited do you guys like the bunk beds
you both get your own bed yeah like this
one up here that's not the older always
cuz I could hop why don't you blow kiss
to your mom and to Kelley into Kevin
okay we hope you like all your new stuff
and you have the most amazing Christmas
ever boy I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this